it's Pete I'm here in New York and today
we're talking to dag from tap add the
eggs the founder and vp of engineering
thanks for being with this deck thank
you for coming so first of all tell us a
little bit at a high level what is tap
at what do you guys do so tap at is a
cross-platform or it's a multi-platform
advertising company where what's called
a demand-side platform so our customers
are the actual advertisers and they buy
advertising through us we're in what's
called a real-time bidded space this
means that we are constantly processing
a lot of potential by opportunities for
for ads and we figure out in real time
if you want to if you want to buy an ad
and how much you're willing to pay for
it and then we put figure out which ad
or which banner or whatever you want to
place there and we do all this in real
time so it's a low latency high
throughput kind of business okay and
tell me about the mobile aspect of your
business so the mobile aspect is there
have have been mobile ad networks for
for quite some time which are fairly I
wouldn't okay not maybe not
unsophisticated but the the mobile space
has been lagging behind in terms of of
the progress has been made in the online
display space over the past few years so
especially on the on the side of a
real-time bidding so we're trying to
bring some of the more sophisticated use
cases or uses of advertising technology
to the mobile space okay and we also
allow customers to do cross-platform
targeting so you don't have to go to one
provider to buy mobile advertising into
another one to get the online display
we're more about one-stop shop see we do
interesting things based on what people
are doing on their mobiles we can we can
can use that for targeting and on their
desktops and vice versa which server has
started Western I'd really well with a
lot of advertisers okay so technically
this means that because you guys are
doing real
bidding there's a high volume low
latency requirement for your for your
architectures are correct yeah so
basically how it works is that whenever
an app or a mobile web page or a
traditional web page is being served
there can be multiple ad units on the
page or in that app as the page is being
rendered or as the application loads
pretty much we have to make a decision
or the whole network the whole system
has to make a decision which includes
quite a few jumps from let's say a
mobile website they call an ad exchange
the ad exchange calls us and a number of
other vendors or demand-side platforms
and we all look at the data that we're
getting we compare that to the campaigns
were running and we return basically a
bid saying okay this is this impression
is worth this much money to us and all
this has to happen before the user
actually notices because you don't want
to show page with a lot of white blanks
on it and Orlin some sort of spinner
loading thing so the requirements are
pretty pretty strong you have to respond
within typically 60 milliseconds and
this includes network round-trip time so
it's that the photo processing time is
very very short okay and and I mean
there are there are companies that have
higher volumes than we do in the online
display space but we are currently
processing about 25,000 requests per
second our servers and that's one reason
I heard that you guys actually made an
interesting decision to move off the
cloud can you talk to us a little bit
about that yeah I mean we we started out
as a lot of companies on on Amazon Cloud
and so the ec2 cloud is is excellent to
get started
and it makes it very cheap to to start
running a service generally though
running on a public cloud where you have
a lot of shared infrastructure makes it
hard for you to to really find the
hotspots fine what's causing jitter in
your performance so when you're running
on virtualized hardware you're running
on shared network infrastructure you're
running on typically shared storage and
we're also a JVM shops we also have
garbage collectors which add to the
whole mix yeah if you have too many
moving parts it makes it really hard to
pinpoint where where are our main
sources of performance issues are they
something that we control or are they in
the actual infrastructure and we realize
that in many cases this was actually in
the infrastructure I'm sure you can you
can you can cope in that in many ways
but to us being able to respond on a
timely basis every single time is very
important so to us the average response
time does really matter much what
matters to us is how many requests or
how many incoming requests are not
handled within that very stringent time
that we have to process it and if we're
losing ten percent the wall requests
because we're having a very high latency
on our 90th percentile that act is
actually might be ten percent lost
business for us because we cherry-pick
every single request and if we miss one
out of ten that's one of the ten dollars
basically okay the other factor is
actually in terms of cost we see that we
can when you start scaling up a little
bit start buying more specialized
Harvard more expensive hardware than
very quickly you get a better
performance ratio with a lone cloud and
we also have some hardware that you
don't even get in the cloud at all like
we're using solid state disks for our
key value stores and we also have some
on the analytics side we have some very
very high memory type harbor and memory
and ram is something that's often very
expensive
in the clouds